C'est une carrière qui mérite
qu'on s'y arrête quelques
minutes, avec nous, l'ancien
premier ministre Lucien Bouchard
au téléphone, bonsoir.
Jean Rochon, c'est vraiment
ironique que ce soit aujourd'hui
qu'on annonce son dessin, alors
qu'on est encore en train de
trouver la meilleure façon de
gérer notre système de santé,
vous avez de son patron, il
rêvait d'un virage ambulatoire,
entre autres, c'est une gros
chose, ça été plus difficile,
c'est la partie plus difficile,
disons. Racontez-nous comment
vous avez vécu cela?
- D'abord, ministre de la Santé
des services sociaux Québec,
c'est un calvaire, c'est un
parcours extrêmement difficile,
épines avec des difficultés à
surmonter plus changer. À
l'époque, Jean Rochon
s'attaquait vraiment au grand
enjeu. C'est quelqu'un que
j'aimais comment, j'ai beaucoup
aimé, je l'ai connu à
l'université, on était étudiant
ensemble, j'étais en droit et il
était en médecine, on travaille
dans les institutions publiques
universitaires, je l'ai connu et
aimé comme ministre, c'était un
très grand ministre, un très
grand courage. Ce qu'il a fait,
c'était très difficile, il a
élaboré dans la gravelle tout le
temps. Le programme d'assurance
médicaments, aujourd'hui, on le
salue, c'est très important,
mais il fallait le faire, c'est
extrêmement difficile, les
contestations de partout, ça été
très difficile de le faire
adopter à l'Assemblée nationale,
il a été critiqué tous les jours
de c'était compliqué de toute
façon. Le virage ambulatoire, il
a même fermer des établissements
sous M. Parizeau, ça prend du
courage de faire ça, et puis il
a travaillé très fort du côté
pour dégager des ressources avec
des coupes qui ont été très mal
perçues, mais la dégager des
ressources qui ont permis de
lancer le virage ambulatoire,
qui ont permis de dégager des
montants qu'on a utilisés pour
évidemment créer des garderies
et services à la petite enfance,
il s'est attaqué au lobby du
tabac, aujourd'hui, on trouve ça
normal, mais à l'époque, il y
avait de la boue comme partout,
comme on dit. Et lui, les
réactions politiques ont été
extrêmement virulentes et il
avait du courage. C'est un homme
qui ne voulait pas parler à tout
le monde, qui voulait poser des
gestes qui allaient changer la
vie des Québécois, qui allait
améliorer le réseau de santé, il
a réussi en très grande partie.
Je suis content
qu'aujourd'hui...
le sort des dirigeants
politiques, il a fallu qu'il
meurt pour qu'on découvre que
c'était un très grand ministre.
Il peut inspirer tout le monde.
Il a fait une carrière
internationale, c'est un homme
humaniste, il a été directeur de
faculté de médecine de Laval,
doctorat en santé publique de
Harvard, un rôle très important
qu'il a joué en santé publique
au sein même des institutions
internationales à Genève,
ensuite, a eu le courage
d'entrer en politique et de
foncer dans le tas, alors qu'il
s'était pas vraiment un
politicien.
- On le soulignait.
- C'est un intellectuel.
- On le soulignait tout à
l'heure que c'était pas un
batailleur politique, chambre,
ce n'est pas là qu'il brillait
le plus, c'était un gentleman,
comme vous le dîtes masculinité
pour objet de venir en politique
et d'être ministre de la Santé
et d'affronter ce calvaire.
- C'est un parlementaire,
un curieux parlementaire du
moins à l'époque, qui répondait
aux questions à la chambre. Ce
n'est pas la formule la plus
facile pour plaire à tout le
monde à la période de questions.
Ça été très difficile pour lui.
C'était à l'époque encore une
fois où les urgences étaient
bondées.
- Il vous demandait plus
d'argent que vous n'aviez pas.
- Tous les jours il y avait un
député de l'expo de l'opposition
qui disait... je vais vous dire
une histoire d'horreur encore...
Jean Rochon se levait...
M. Rochon, voulez-vous répondre
à mon électeur?
Je trouvais que c'était un
calvaire. Il acceptait, et le
faisait parce qu'il était
courageux, ce n'était pas avec
bonheur qu'il a protesté
critique. Malgré cela, il
persistait, il continuait. Moi,
ça été un des ministres pour
lequel j'ai le plus
d'admiration.
- C'est quand même
extraordinaire, je le disais
d'entrée de jeu, on apprend de
nouvelles aujourd'hui, alors que
M. Legault, des années plus
tard, dit : on va tenter de
décentraliser le système que
l'on va tenter de faire ce lit
ceci ou cela, on voit à quel
point notre réseau de santé est
presque ingérable.
- Si on regarde le niveau du
personnel politique qui a
travaillé dans le domaine de la
santé, cette de très haut
niveau, c'est pas des gens qui
étaient incompétents, vous
savez, M. Castonguay, M.
Legault, Mme Roy, M. Barrette
et d'autres très grands
ministre, il y a eu des
personnalités absolument
exceptionnelles, alors le
réseau, c'est un casse-tête et
je peux vous dire que j'ai déjà
vu une personne que j'ai
connue... cette personne
ministre... qui dit : oui,
j'accepte mais c'est pas mal
afin de ma carrière politique.
(indistinct)